joining me now is Brandon Judd he is the
president of the National Border Patrol
Union Mark Krikorian
executive director of the Center for
Immigration Studies and saman necessary
an immigration attorney and activist
Brandon I want to start with you you
were part of that White House meeting
that ended with the authorization of
force along the border is this all an
invented threat at the border in your
estimation as many in the media are now
saying no absolutely not all you have to
do is look at the number of people that
are gathering in Tijuana that are that
are waiting to come across the border
and these threats that they're gonna
storm our ports of entry are obvious an
obvious sign that they do not care about
our laws that they're going to do what
they need to do for their own benefit
instead of doing it in a legal manner
again if you look when I was in that
meeting what I saw is I saw an
unwavering determination to secure the
board for for the American public for
the safety of the American public and we
appreciate that and we appreciate that
determination that the president has
some on your reaction I mean the look
this is the head of the border Union
that he knows what's going on there
given what his members are feeding back
to him your reaction and I think the
conversation shouldn't be so much about
the caravan but I think the caravan
sheds light more on the fact that our
immigration system is truly broken the
fact that this is what's considered a
real threat is 5,000 people coming to
the border seeking asylum why is that
why are they the issue why isn't the
system the issue because these people
have been stampeded they haven't rushed
the border they're not carrying weapons
with them no one has seen them try to
hurt anybody so why are we making the
people escaping their problems the issue
why we why don't we trying to criticize
the actual immigration system and fix
that problem well let's hold it there a
minute saman I mean they there are
abuses of the asylum system going on
asylum is when you're under persecution
not just because I'd like a better job
in a nicer neighborhood right mark
Krikorian
your reaction well that's exactly right
I mean I'd say that the broader system
is the problem and the system is we have
Asylum rules that incentivize people
to make these bogus asylum claims to
essentially use asylum as a strategy for
illegal immigration because none of
these people has any realistic
expectation of actually getting
political asylum at the end of the day
they're doing this to apply for asylum
as a way of getting past the border and
then they're home free this has been
going on since the Obama administration
really kind of not incentivized it and
you know we're still dealing with the
fallout from it that's why we have this
caravan and that's why there are other
caravans behind them that are trying to
do the same thing I want to roll this
tape this is Kirsten Nielsen the
homeland security chief along the border
listen the reality is that there are
currently over 6200 individuals camped
out south of the US border in Tijuana
today as I stand here in Mexicali there
are more than 3,000 caravan members
these two groups combined with other
caravans making their way through the
northern triangle in Mexico will result
in approximately eight to ten thousand
migrants amassing along our southern
border the crisis is real and it is just
on the other side of this wall your
reaction I want to go to Brandon Jed
well again if you look at this this is
not about legal immigration this is
about illegal immigration if those
people are not there they're not gonna
wait until they go through the ports of
entry they're going to cross the border
illegally and the first act that they're
gonna make when they come to the United
States is an illegal act that should
make everybody a little bit concerned
about what the motives are what about
the criminal element here that's being
reported they claim they have 500
criminals as part of these caravans some
on does that mean nothing to you we
should just open up let these people in
let them come in under the asylum laws
no and I think that's the wrong
characterization of the argument and I
don't think these people aren't coming
to the position Zaman it's not a
characterization at all it's a position
Camille and security
right now this is what there's still
evidence of that issued a memo no
Department of home asked here's already
issued a memo saying hey we need to work
with Mexico to try to vet these people
in Mexico keep them in Mexico go through
the asylum process there and then the
que take it on a case-by-case basis and
see you qualify see who doesn't pass
them to the point of entry there's
absolutely no evidence or no proof that
these guys are going to show up to the
port of entry bum-rush the border and
run through and become quote unquote
illegal immigrants they're coming to the
border seeking asylum and it's unfair to
say that all of them don't have a
plausible case because some of them
really do probably have a very plausible
case and unfortunately they get washed
up with the ones that are just coming
here because they want a better job but
the truth is there are a handful of them
a good few dozen I would say even a few
hundred then they have a good case that
are living in bad conditions that have
seen people get murdered and then have
had family members get murdered I see
them I try to wait dozens of people from
my office why say I can't help you don't
have a good case or everyone's know well
someone in this situation comes in has a
good case there's no doubt the asylum
laws need to be revisited but perhaps
we've not been looking at them in the
right way and I think you know we can't
just have every my father waited a year
in line before he even had his papers
recognized then he came into the country
with a sponsor then he served in the
military before becoming a citizen there
has to be an orderly process thank you
gentlemen all for your contributions
here now to explore whether the
president has the constitutional
authority to use US troops to protect
the border and a mayor on American soil
the border agents were joined by Donald
Kramer he's a former intelligence
officer an Iraq veteran and Joel Rubin
former Obama Deputy Secretary of State
Joel I want to start with you you
believe the president was wrong to send
the troops to the border because of the
unclear mission but isn't protecting the
southern border and enforcing standing
immigration laws mission enough well
right there is no mission there's no
military mission here there's no clarity
about the end point what the objectives
will be for these soldiers and really
even if there's a technical ability of
the President to send the troops there
it's it's a bad judgment and it this
president has a habit of using our
troops as political props
that was the intent for this prior to
the midterm elections to turn out the
vote and really these troops are doing
nothing there they're sitting there
waiting they're doing support we have
civilian enforcement that can do the job
we don't need to have our troops at the
border Donald are you concerned about
this so-called human stampede that has
been threatened is that a reality and
it's that similar to what we saw in the
summer when the border was under such
pressure
well this Stampede if you will is a very
real reality and a lot of these folks
that are coming to our border are known
criminals and we've already found cases
of weapons among them and and you know
even in Tijuana they're talking about
disorderly contact drunkenness these are
not the type of people that we won in
the United States you know I applaud the
president maybe all of his tactics
aren't always the best but we have a
right to protect our borders Donald I
want to play something for you angel
this is Senator Kamala Harris she said
this the other day I want to get your
reaction these folks who are being
deployed there they're going to believe
there if they have left their families
they will not be home looks like for
Thanksgiving and all because there
needed to be some demonstration for the
TV cameras based on a political agenda
instead of what is a national security
threat Donald does the president have
the authority to deploy troops in this
way there is that actor that Posse
Comitatus Act that forbids using the
military to enforce domestic law does
that apply here well these off these
soldiers and and forces they're not law
enforcement officials but he does have
the right to deploy them because it is
his right as commander-in-chief
to support this country whether it's a
humanitarian or supporting our borders
and this is something that's you know
been precedent before you know President
Nixon did it President Reagan did it
President Bush did it and President
Obama did it it's been done before it's
his right and he has to protect this
country Joel your reaction well I really
believe that we could find the hundred
million dollars that we spent on sending
the troops there better uses for that
money we could be sending it to the
countries to help stabilize them so
people know
leave they don't believe there's a
national security patrol I believe that
our civilian agents from DHS are capable
of handling this and I don't believe
that we need to have troops at the
border now being authorized to shoot at
a caravan of individuals who there are
some unruly ones but by and large the
overwhelming majority are women and
children waiting in camps to go through
an asylum process well it's not all
women and children or you wouldn't have
the 3000 you've got people with coke
possession they're carrying weapons
they're being arrested now by the two
about the Tijuana government and and and
the civilian police can handle that as
they should and the orderly process or
the process that is in place is working
and it should work we don't need to have
military troops there to enforce the
process that is already being executed
properly Donald your thoughts do we need
those troops or not or or it's drunk
just playing fast and loose here no I do
think we need the troops you know right
now CBP is 80 percent undermanned right
now and if only for a short period if
these troops can support them to do the
logistic things so that the CBP officers
can do their job then that's important
you know if they're observing and
they're providing support then let them
do their jobs so that CBP can actually
perform what they're hired to do
gentlemen I'll give each of you a shot
at this
should the president close the border
down does he have the authority to do so
Donald you first then Joel very quickly
ten seconds each whether or not he
should or should not that remains
question as we look forward to the the
the caravan and the move forward does he
have the authority
absolutely it's his right to defend this
country to defend our borders and to
protect the United States citizens yeah
Joel if he believes heard as a national
security threat
clearly he can close down the border
national security threat should always
be dealt with but it's an American value
to allow people seeking asylum to come
here to this country we need to keep
that border open for those people well
we let a million people in a year as
citizens I think that's that shows the
welcoming spirit of America thank you
gentlemen